vladimir putin's long meeting table was
both comic and tragic an illustration of
the diplomatic distance between russia
and the west in the lead-up to the
invasion the pre-war efforts of france's
emanuel macron came to nothing despite
years of french involvement in peace
talks for the breakaway portion of the
donbass region which russia recognized
as independent before launching its
ukraine invasion still he continues to
engage with putin i think it's useful
for the americans actually for other
europeans at least one leader
that is in contact with with mr putin
even if on the surface there might be
some tensions there
another nato member attempting mediation
is turkey hosting a summit between
ukraine and russia's foreign ministers
two weeks ago turkey has a complex
relationship with russia it has not
imposed sanctions but it has restricted
black sea access to russian warships
at thursday's nato summit turkish
president erdogan was eager to stress
nato poses no direct threat to russia
but turkey has sold drones to ukraine
turkey has deep economic interests here
at the political engagement i think the
ukrainians trust turkey and after all
they have hosted already a senior level
meeting a possible mediator outside nato
is israel prime minister naftali bennett
visited putin in moscow this month
bennett says it's his moral duty to help
israel and russia have common enemies in
the war in syria and it has strong ties
to jewish diasporas in both russia and
ukraine putin claimed the invasion was
to denazify ukraine but it has forced
thousands of jews to flee how we can
bring about a ceasefire pakistan's
leader imran khan has suggested islamic
countries and china get involved
likely unappealing to vladimir zelinski
because many of those nations abstained
from a u.n resolution condemning the
invasion ukraine's president insists he
wants to meet with putin there's a lot
of people go into this very hemden
because
there's no way he can agree to many of
the concessions that we know russia is
putting forth giving uh you know
recognition of crimea as russian
territory recognition of the dumbass for
now it appears guns missiles and bombs
are doing all the talking redmond
shannon global news london